good afternoon everyone my name is Dr
Miller and the SCP we're going to be
looking at today is SCP
4415 object class
uid special containment procedures as CP
4415 is self-contained within site 17's
humanoid containment Wing to mitigate
the potential loss of an anomalous
humanoid during testing SCP 4051 it
should be administered a class s Slow
Burn amnestic prior to each exploration
of SCP 4415 the amnestic should be
activated after each
Mission description SCP 4415 is a set of
extradimensional locations accessible
through through the door of the former
humanoid containment unit Lambda 45 SCP
4415 interior serves as a way point for
multiple extra spatial and extemporal
locations which present themselves semi-
randomly once the unit's door has been
fully shut and reopened additionally SCP
4415 is only accessible to anomalous
humanoids attempts to re-enter SCP 4415
by non-anomalous persons have been
universally unsuc successful reality
within unit Lambda 45 often fluctuates
and is not entirely comport to Baseline
but is capable of sustaining human life
indefinitely several entities most
anomalous in their own right have
resided within for a considerable length
of time due to readily accessible food
sources and shelter the primary source
of water within each location is a large
river ostensibly similar throughout
locations suggesting SCP 4415 may be a
vast singular geological structure the
purpose of exploratory missions within
SCP
4415 has primarily been to discover the
nature origin and intent of its
hypothetical Creator SCP 451 has been
selected to achieve this end due to its
proximity to SCP 4415 and past
exploratory
experience extradimensional SPAC is
encountered by SCP 4051
include 1 B7
44151 description a dense forest of
deciduous meal an offshoot of the
central river forms a small pond
approximately 100 m from unit Lambda
45's door inhabitant a female humanoid
with notable scarring to the hands torso
and scalp subject demonstrated an
extreme aversion to human contact 1 B7
two description a flat geometric plane
surrounded by free floating digital
polygons a flow of polygons is visible
some distance from unit Lambda 45's door
inhabitant a younger male humanoid with
ontokinetic capabilities subjects seem
to have inconsistent physical form and
have its face Dem manifested during
attempted questioning 1 B7
4415 03
description a modest domicile
overlooking an Ocean Cliff inhabitant an
elderly male humanoid with theric and
occult symbols inscribed onto its body
subject possessed significant physical
Trauma from an unknown source 1 B7
44154 description location exists in a
state of spatial Fluxx but generally
possessed a purple Hue inhabitant and a
morphis entity with metamorphic
capabilities often presenting as two
female humanoids subjects possessed mild
Clairvoyance but could rarely
communicate
intelligibly 1 B7
44155 description a stone Spire inside
of which is an unoccupied and
unremarkable Library a steady flow of
water from beneath the Spire generates
the central River inhabitant
non-applicable document
44151 exploration of 1 B7
44155 site director Eyes Only access
denied document 4415 2 SCP 4415
inhabitants site director Eyes Only
access denied document 44:15 3 wrise a
petition regarding SCP 445 site director
Eyes Only access
denied skip next email one new
message to site 17 director Thomas
Graham from Junior researcher Natalie
Reams subject
concerns hey Graham just got done
reading the SCP 445 documentation I
believe it's only been a month since
that project concluded all the
excitement of working on a Bonafide
cross test makes it feel like it was
just yesterday and many of the details
are still fresh in my mind
that said I had some questions about the
items you restricted to level 4 4415
clearance given their perance to the SCP
4415 project as a whole as we discovered
together the library within ib7
44155 was seemingly penned by a CB 4415
Creator however this detail was emitted
from the official documentation for
reasons I find suspect fortunately for
us both I saved a copy of the text that
SCP 4051 retrieved from the central
bookshelf I have attached it
below the old man stopped coming to see
me after a while I think he was promoted
to the council which seems right hope
he's doing well now after he left Graham
started running the show mean
motherucker he's lucky I was keeping
myself in this cell so I didn't eras his
power tripping ass with the full weight
of time and space
shouldn't talk like that the old man
wouldn't like it solitary confinement is
getting to me I think honestly if it
weren't for my neighbors in the other
units I don't think I'd have lasted this
long first one was a teenager the grunts
outside their door kept talking about
plants so I take it they can control
them or some such we talk through the
walls sometimes about who they were and
what they wanted and i' bend reality so
the GRS couldn't hear us they were a
good kid they were gone inside a month
though next was a boy in a computer
couldn't talk to him as easy because of
all the ones and zeros but I got the
gist he was a lot like me actually
except way
smarter he lived in a little virtual
world and knew all the ins and outs of
his machine Graham wanted him to help
run this system they have set up here I
think they call it apath where they
flood the site with the medic agents and
put amnestics in the ventilation to keep
their personnel in
line kind of but stones from glass
houses I guess thing is it kept getting
harder to interface with the kid I Tred
to talk at nights and it' be like
certain parts of him just couldn't
answer it got to the point he just throw
up an error message Hardware inoperable
I think and I just couldn't get through
to him third was an old man with a ton
of tattoos when you saw him you got the
sense he'd been around the world and
seen a lot Graham must have wanted what
was in his head too because he'd be
escorted out of his cell every morning
and to return in the evening with a few
new injuries didn't get many chances to
talk even if he wanted to he didn't come
back one night I'm pretty sure my last
neighbor was actually two people not
sure what their deal was but the
researchers tested a lot of psychic
anomalies on them think one of the
experiments messed their heads up a lot
and they were never the same after that
before the accident I could hear them
Comfort one another every night I could
tell they really loved each other I have
a confession to make though broke my
promise to the old man I left my cell
last night I walked the halls of sight
17 and made all the grunts forget they
saw me I had a general idea of where I
was going slipping through walls and
cement barriers as I traveled down into
the facility's depth there was this
awful stench and it grew as I descended
floor six is where I found the
source I almost cried two corpses one
young one old a computer terminal
assembled on the ground with a nasty
crack through it screen and it was a
thing a thing there used to be two
people and those were just the ones on
top and then site director Thomas Graham
shanked me in the goddamn ribs never
even saw it coming just felt the
incision in my side as I fell face first
into my
neighbors I turned and saw some faceless
grunt mother and his hands raised over
me for the killing blow holding a dagger
with a glowing purple blade it didn't
look like Scranton
Tech it looked like my neighbors I made
everything stop I made everything go
away I made
everything I made
I'm going to make everything better that
knife hurt me bad I can't tell how much
reality I can bend at this point but
it's not much I can't believe how stupid
I was last night walking into a grave of
course Graham knew I was here he's been
tearing anomalies apart ever since he
got here in the hopes he can build
something
better he made a knife that leeches
omnipotence and gave it to one of his
lackeys to to finish me but I'm not
finished I can still raise the dead and
I can keep them safe it it kill me but I
can do it weathers if you're reading
this somehow just know I ended up as a
good guy I'm going to bring these people
back as best I
can and give him a place to
stay maybe he'll come back here someday
and you can help us you can give these
people a life that was better than the
one they lost please somebody help us
now then let's drop the pretenses of
joviality the contents of this
transcript are damning I've done more
dinging on my own after working with
4051 and it seems like every document
involving you is contaminated by
redactions and mimic kill agents judging
by Dr saman's note in SCP 4175
documentation the Ethics Committee has
began to notice your methods
and they aren't pleased if someone were
to forward the attached transcript to
them it would most likely set off an
extensive investigation into your
activities as site
director naturally I wouldn't do
something like that to you without
hearing from you first what I need to
know is that there's a rational ethical
explanation for what you've been doing
if you can give that explanation to me
and I find it convincing I'll hold off
on drafting the petition to the
committee
best wishes Dr Natalie
[Music]
Reams new message two Junior researcher
Natalie Reams from site 17 director
Thomas Graham subject regarding
concerns RS I really did think better of
you when I arrived at this site Lambda
45 contained an undocumented class 5
reality Bender Who had struck a person
bond with my
predecessor by its own admittance it was
contained by its Good Will alone a
nuclear warhead in control of its own
devation and now it's a dead thing in
another world and all it take was some
occult Knowledge from a person of
interest and the psychic abilities of
two
clairo how on Earth could this be
considered an ethical violation I saved
this facility rooms every day I save it
in aund ways that you would never
understand and you never
will you told me that you need an
explanation for my
actions I do not care all that much
about convincing you as with the
foundation and its enemy the Victor is
the party with a bigger stick my stick
in this case is the latent mic agents
scattered through this email and Class A
amnestics currently flooding your office
space just let the induced paralysis run
its course as the drugs take your
memories away this is hardly your first
time I really did enjoy working with you
on the SCP 445 project nly I could see
why T your fancy do so best watches Dr
Thomas cram director of site
[Music]
17 this concludes today's lecture thank
you for listening if indeed you still
are and you are all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to
zargaran
bigp O crop guy James Saba Irish
wristwatch Lost Boy
segnar your local Foundation agent
zazan worthy fire copster Dean
Dingus that loser braded peit Ruan
O'Brien
grimnir extra moments
123 Swift raw Ordu
malas Big Booty Judy Desmond K and
oscuro
vision if you would like a special thank
you at the end of each of my videos and
some other cool stuff as well as well
visit
patreon.com slthe vulgan thank
[Music]
you